novembre 2014
le prix du baril de pétrole est en
pleine chute lors d'une rencontre de
l'opep à vienne
tous les yeux se tournent vers l'arabie
saoudite le poids lourd est contestée le
géant hal et il consentir à une
réduction de sa production pour
permettre de stabiliser voire de faire
remonter les prix la réponse de son
ministre est venu catégorique inflexible
pas question pour l'arabie saoudite de
ralentir sa production
le prix du baril de pétrole poursuivait
sa descente vertigineuse
c'est la première fois que ils disent on
va rien faire et on veut maintenir notre
production on n'a jamais fait ça dans
dans le marché du pétrole parce que
c'est un c'est une industrie c'est un
secteur critique
il est extrêmement important pourquoi ce
refus sans précédent de jouer les grands
arbitres du marché arabie saoudite
serait essentiellement motivée par un
désir de préserver sa part du lion sur
un marché mondial transformer l'uranium
est en guerre en guerre économique selon
cet analyste
on voit bien que son idée c'est de
montrer qu'elle reste le maître du jeu
sur le pétrole et que effectivement il
reste les grands producteurs ils veulent
essentiellement contrecarrer toute la
partie production de pétrole de schiste
dont qui vient d'amérique du nord
en ayant cette stratégie l'arabie
saoudite demeure le plus important
exportateur de pétrole avec 13 % du
marché mondial mais sa place au sommet
est menacée elle n'a donc pas
l'intention d'initiés seule une
réduction de sa production pour
redresser les cours de l'or noir et par
le fait même aidé la concurrence il ne
contrôle pas la production en dehors de
l'opecst qui est extrêmement large qui
elle va continuer à augmenter et donc il
va nécessairement ramener le prix vers
le bas et donc automatiquement l'arabie
saoudite va devoir réduire sa production
pour un aigle prix vers le haut et donc
ils ne sont pas prêts à le faire tous
aller certains analystes croient plutôt
que l'arabie saoudite fait un calcul
géostratégique con
certes et avec les états unis pour
mettre à genoux certains pays
exportateurs et opposant politique sur
l'échiquier du moyen-orient nommément la
russie et l'iran en assam à crois qu'il
s'agit d'une conséquence fortuite mais
qui n'est pas sans déplaire
certainement s'il ya des side effects
politique certainement certains pays
vont être beaucoup plus coincé
financièrement et on le voit déjà la
russie l'iran est certainement l'arabie
saoudite ne va pas être très malheureuse
pour parce que ces pays sont moins de
marges financières et donc peut-être
politique
l'arabie saoudite elle a les reins
solides bien que plus de 90% des revenus
de l'état proviennent de la vente de
pétrole et le croit pouvoir jouer de
patience avec un marché qui finira bien
par lui donner raison
l'arabie saoudite elle a un coût
d'extraction qui est très faible qui aux
alentours de cinq ou six dollars donc
pour extraire le pétrole
à cela il faut ajouter donc une marge
d'exploitation une marge opérationnelle
globalement je dirais que au dessus de
15 20 dollars en fait l'arabie saoudite
réalise un profit un profit oui mais il
ne suffiraient pas à combler les
dépenses de l'état pour soutenir les
généreux programme de subventions à sa
population est essentielle au maintien
de la paix sociale en arabie saoudite
il faudra puiser dans le bas de laine
ils ont environ 700 milliards de dollars
en réserves et donc eux ils se
considèrent très à l'aise avec un prix
plus bas
ils n'ont pas réduit leurs dépenses
ils ont annoncé qu'ils étaient prêts à
prendre
un déficit sur leurs budgets 2015 et
possiblement 2016 pour le moment le
royaume ne montre aucun signe de
faiblesse
au contraire le roi salman qui a accédé
au trône en pleine dégringolade des
cours du pétrole vient d'annoncer la
distribution de milliards de dollars en
bonus aux employés de l'état et à divers
organismes
le contrat social semble-t-il dire est
intacte des largesses de la monarchie
vont se poursuivre ces sujets peuvent
dormir en paix